il a lui-même désacraliser sa fonction
il n'a lui même pas respecté sa fonction
j'évoquerai le la fête de la musique
avec un groupe gay j'évoquerai la
fameuse photo avec les deux jeunes noirs
qui lui font des gestes obscènes
j'évoquerai même son comportement dans
la rue a interpellé un jeune homme et
lui disant vous souvenez ah bah moi je
traverse la rue et je vous trouve du
travail
il n'a pas engagé comme ça un dialogue
avec un quidam il est président de la
république il est le roi
il s'est lui-même désacralisée il est
donc il a ce qu'il mérite si j'ose dire
c'est horrible à dire
alors merci d'être là à 10 cordier sa
valise ça va être ça va bien bonsoir
soir david guiraud porte parole de la
france à son fils vers simon david
savard et jean-baptiste moreau député la
république en marche vous êtes porte
parole aussi la république en marche
pour lui déplaire
non non on n'est pas un mec ou une nana
on est aussi là bas il ya la parité
d'exercice mais on se sent se
démultiplient on essaie avec les
croyants mais si on a doucement est très
actif il fait de la crise c'est génial
les scieries vous avez vu la phrase de
eric zemmour moi je m'en est ce que est
ce que vous accepter ça cette phrase
d'eric et ben oui vous oui j'suis sûr
j'ai un discours un peu plus et qui dit
oui m'enfin expliquer expliquer n'est
pas justifié à ce qu'il mérite est de
bush il a ce qui ne risque rien n'est
fait n'est pas justifié ou on l'a dit ça
mais attendez quand on est un quand on
est face à ce qui s'est passé avec le
président de la république
on est là pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé ce qu'il mérite
maintenant je sais c'est son pote bah
oui c'est sont pas non non c'est le fit
toutes les deux heures on dirait la team
rocket rsa prix
[Applaudissements]
il va ramener toute la soirée pourrait
bien des choses la france a solide qui
défend macron ces vivants là bas confie
si l'adversaire soumises là en
l'occurrence elle défend gêner le
premier à dire c'était un geste
inadmissible inacceptable en démocratie
ça on peut pas me faire sera versée la
non mais j'essaie le premier a twitté
avant il a tweeté que c'est un type
d'extrême gauche en revanche connaît pas
beaucoup de types d'extrême gauche qui
élimine qu'anticipé divertir le truc
parce qu'il avait un temps pour se vider
ap royal et jean messi à ça ça vous a
échappé
j'en vois d'ailleurs pu se mettre en
jambes et si on est là pour entendre
uniquement la france insoumise et que
j'ai pas un droit de parole alors là non
non aujourd'hui non non mais je vais
t'éclater quelques jours je dois faire
je fais un acte révolutionnaire qui
devrait être appelé par ckoi les
français est bas mais non mais je vais
te dire c'est où tu parles quand on te
dit tu t'arrêtes quand on te le dis
sinon tu vas pas mais la règle doit être
la même pour tous pas seulement pour ben
behe coiffeur dit de david c'est terminé
c'est terminé non non non non non non
non être une radio soit en fait moi je
pense les français n'aiment pas la
violence ouais je pense que les gens y
donne pas l'image est en fait c'est vrai
non mais des fois des fois ça pète dans
des manifs et c'est ça pète et la jfp
signer là ce qui l'a mis il a regagné
rider s'organiser il avait prévu de le
faire et en plus c'est par surprise
c'est quand même pas très courageuse est
vif et c'est fait par des militants des
tips et des royalistes
il pense que le roi doit revenir et
salle à ce qu'on a à ce que j'ai en face
de moi les gens les siens c'est toute
une galaxie de gens qui se connaissent
qui se fréquente qui s'aiment bien là
l'est des antilles par exemple ou pas
par exemple finalement la section
monsieur mélenchon n'en parlerais
janvier lorsque vous regardez
les coulées mais sincèrement balech de
thaïlandais sur le sujet en fait
président anaky et surtout sujet si vous
avez un vieux sujet vous allez suivre
sur tout ce qui m'a fait un match dont
c'est bizarre quand vous êtes un
collectif féministe vous défendez eric
zemmour qui est visé par cette femme qui
porte plainte pour enfin qui dénonce des
agressions sexuelles je sais pas ce que
vous faites dans votre vie vous dit vous
êtes féministe fait vous êtes féministe
que quand c'est des noirs et des arabes
des arabes khalti vous allez dire juste
une chose les gens ils veulent pas voir
ces images il ya des moments où c'est
vrai moi c'est vrai ça peut être des
fois même sur les réseaux sociaux
au relais des conneries des trucs un peu
folle pastore hic des images mais bon ça
reste des images quoi l'extrême droite
ça fait longtemps que nous on a l'air
parce que moi je reçois des menaces de
gens d'extrême droite âgé ans on a gardé
alors j'y ai goûté ces gens ils sont
dangereux
voilà c'est tout ils ont envahi le
conseil régional le conseil régional
d'occitanie sté l'action française
pareil des royalistes aller montjoie
saint denis les matchs aimerait qu'on
reste sur eric zemmour eric zemmour a
dit il a ce qu'il mérite
êtes vous choqué par les propos d'eric
zemmour je veux qu'on reste sur ce sujet
on a treize minutes ensemble si on
déborde on arrête
ok merci lazio qui personne ne mérite de
claques oui je suis choqué que personne
ne mérite des claques dans une
démocratie pas plus ce république leur
président de la république que vous que
moi que notre église points peut
maintenant personne la mairie de classe
on peut avoir des discussions enflammées
on peut faire des reproches aux
présidents public il est là pour ça pour
les écouter on a des désaccords profonds
avec la france insoumise c'est pas pour
ça que je déteste alexis corbière on
s'entend en dehors globalement bien on a
des vraies discussions et des vrais
désaccords
voilà et on a des vrais débats
démocratiques mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'on va se taper dessus face à des
repas de saint jean d'âcre incident
alors un public juste j'aime entendre
les noms dans l'équipe il y en a quatre
qui disent non et qui sont pas choqués
vous non mais je suis pas oubliée parce
que c'est eric zemmour et il fait du
zemmour était alors à brosser lors de
jeux vous dire pourquoi je pense que
c'est une stratégie de sa part de dire
l'opposé de ce que toute la classe
politique penche pour qu'on identifie
comme un âne opposés au gouvernement
parce que c'est un secret pour personne
eric zemmour il a de plus en plus envie
de faire de la politique donc non ça ne
me choque pas de sa part alors sature
pas delphine ou parce que aujourd'hui en
fait le pays va mal dans tous les sens
du terme et les gens deviennent de plus
en plus violents ils en ont marre ils
pensent que l'état ne gère pas bien le
problème
le problème c'est que le président ait
le visage est le représentant donc avec
tout ce qui s'est passé
moi avec les violences limite ce serait
peut-être même arrivé avant donc bien
sûr ça doit pas arriver mais les gens
sont tellement violent et c'est lui le
visage de nikos et franchement je les
oublie son nom s'est passé inscrits mais
moi vivant mais jamais j'aurais pu
penser un jour il ya un président de la
république se prendre une claque dans la
gueule est ce qu'il ya de plus eu mignon
un président de la république qui sait
jamais c'est un choc
de l'autre côté
même des gens sur le plateau hier qui
dit je condamne mais il le mérite
non un président de la république ne
peut pas mérité une claque mais personne
ne mérite une claque nom isabelle mo
ibrahim kamal j'ai condamné cette ville
je ne détiens tout ce que je déteste
mais quand on lit molly vous dit il à ce
qu'ils méritent c'est pas le même
discours qu'eric zemmour est important
parce qu'on me dise maîtres libye j'ai
une voix qui porte
cantini de ce qu'ils méritent il veut
dire par là que le président a lui-même
voulu un système qui viennent va péter à
la gueule que je pense et moi je dis moi
ce qui m'énerve et je vous adore vous le
savez mais ce qui me dérange dans votre
discours là c'est pourquoi voulez vos
livres n'aurait pas le droit de le dire
ce qu'ils méritent
tandis que zemmour il a voulu une
logique
grand attendu ya du tout la même chose
s'il vous plaît un mec qui parle
d'immeubles ah oui oui si vous le dire
ici mais la raison qui d'abord et
manuelle malot si tu veux la paix
schuitema emmanuel emmanuel parot a
voulu ainsi et il a voulu un système où
c'est un président tactile qui va au
contact des gens donc effectivement mal
gérée alors entonné un président
totalement ouvert on ne peut pas être
ouvert qu'aux positif on peut aussi le
risque de se prendre effectivement mata
meilleur un gendarme et elle a d'abord
dit non ça c'est là ça c'est la première
choix de la meilleure émission jeu
bon moi je me tiens mais serena mais
jamais c'est bon il est vexé c'est très
bien j'avais loupé tu peux pas dire ça
tu peux pas dire parce qu'un président
va au contact
il mérite de produire et que j'aime pas
je n'ai pas dit kim aris que tu me suis
dit alors salade la deuxième la deuxième
chose c'est que quand j'entends les gens
de la france insoumise
voilà nous dire que c'est un art le mec
a fait sa classe et un royaliste a
laissé le bonheur pour les tenants et
les gens n'arrêtent elle est apolitique
et mes mecs les mêmes mecs qui n'ont pas
un mot quand il sait la mise
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas de prendre parti
c'est bien ce que je dis de maisons
d'accord et quoi les mecs qui qualifie
le repos avec déséquilibré notamment
catherine désarticulé drapeau soviétique
est complètement et jeudi mais contre
les groupuscules jafari voir un jour
arriver
je crois que tu n'as plus jeunes la
mission préparatoire
parce que tu me fatigues notons la dîme
de la danse je suis tout ça quand je te
dis non seulement passé avec david guion
bien sûr mais tu m'as non contradictoire
écoute non je sors pas je vais te
soutenir non mais faut le dire mais je
suis pas moi sans rien fait je vais
sortir le gauchiste
alors il s'est même chose donc c'est
vrai je suis par les fils jean je vais
t'expliquer quelque chose on n'est pas
d'accord avec tout ce que dit la france
ici j'ai l'impression que si j'étais des
copies l'abruti laissez moi de parler
parce que je t'ai fric tu es toujours
hors sujet non je suis politis toujours
le truc je t'ai dis je c'est coudre non
non je suis jetée dijon est une fan je
te dis que je suis petite croissance a
soumis jeudi l'est pas
j'ai ce type y attend des gens super a
dit ce qu'on attendait mais juste très
rapidement parce qu'il m'a rapidement
il dit que la france à 6 mois quand
zemmour il s'est fait gifler j'ai twitté
pour paris oui donc taisez-vous des noms
non pas parce que votre pote vous êtes
toujours comme cul et chemise mais non
on dirait minus et glisse et ça c'est
vraiment arrêter c'est une façon de
parler tu le chu ce nom mais sais-tu
c'est une remarque est très
désobligeantes très sexiste d'autant
plus que tu t'installes hétéro
ce soit chez que j'aime beaucoup ta côté
de la planète n'est pas à côté de la
plaque tu as politisé tu veux dire nous
ici on innove france a soumis ce nid est
raide ni au milieu se soit abattue vers
plus souvent que donc arrête nous fait
chier la marine et à banon mais il
arrête mais j'ai tendance à ménard et de
toi je te le dis rien mais il ya un truc
tout simple
ces trois figures parce que les gens il
faut ce qu'il faut voir là dedans c'est
que des fois il ya des fois par exemple
les actes de violence et de la colère
extra mais lui là le type kahlaoui sa
royalistes qui pensent que le président
dans le droit la liste et si ça doit
demander à vos cv 5 gilles bailly comme
votre anatomie et et les gens ils
pensent que le roi il doit revenir comme
le québec est riche en humour quand tu
dis oui le président a désacralisation
mais chirac il aller au contact des gens
bien sûr héros il a nommé tient alors il
fait ce qu'il veut alors 17 mai commence
avec un président qui est jupiter et
tripoli ce soir temps mais pas une daube
un nom mais pas le dollar tu as des
pétards et les simbas dispard l'a dit ça
peut-être te venir en aide mais en fait
déjà eric zemmour il a dit qu'il ne
connaisse une et pas du tout l'acte il a
dit que le condamné
en revanche il a dit oui à une
désacralisation et puis la deuxième
chose ce qui l'expliqué dans il mérite
s'il met une humiliation c'est quand
même une personne macron qu'ils allaient
dire les élus les français s'étaient
enfin dès qu'il part en déplacement à
chaque fois on a l'impression qu'il
n'est pas fier de son peuple
on a entendu traverse la rue tu
trouveras du travail mais la firme une
régie pub qui font entendre aussi et
c'est normal que vous avez aussi explosé
mais s'est fait humilié mais parce
qu'ils nous
aujourd'hui de violences n'ont jamais
juste trente secondes comme un jarret
vacances et nous ça ne finira bien fini
alors elle n'arrête pas de dire qu'elle
défend les formes diverses et raccordé
pleine bourre d'urfé muscadet a par
contre la ja bref pas son nom est
vraiment ce qu'il explique s'égosiller
un peuple qui en a assez on l'a vu avec
les gilet jaune
et là il est arrivé comme ça au contact
ce que doit faire un président c'est
c'est pas le problème
par contre les gens dont l'opa oublient
ils ont encore laissé hier et j'ai je ne
vois pas de perdant à dire il a ce qu'il
mérite mais il est ce qu'ils méritent de
temps dans l'humiliation qui fera taire
tout ça on l'a entendu trois heures marc
van thiel vous savez ce qu'il a dit en
plus comptés il a ajouté il a dit il a
dit pour désacraliser la fonction il a
dit qu'il était contre la fête de la
musique avec un groupe g il est ressorti
tous les trucs c'est homophobes et
racistes mairie qui l'a dit la photo
avec les deux jeunes noirs qui lui
ferait il a sorti tout ça pour justifier
cette heureuse il arrive aux candidats
de la région mais quand on désacralise
la fonction à telle enseigne et parler
avec l'ensemble des français c'est la
wii c'est le rôle de la c'était
hallucinant quand il se fait prendre en
photo avec deux types qui font des
droits d'honneur et alan donneurs qui
sont des malfrats il a pas donné un
malfrat excusez moi si c'est pas
désacralisé la fonction ce soit l'aspect
des ferries et moore et vous vous avez
récupéré encore le tout comme le haut
lieu non non mais au lieu de dire si la
bbc oui mais aujourd'hui j'en ai
vraiment ras la casquette des gens qui
nous accusent en permanence de
récupération et d'instruments section
france a soumise à la regarder
instrumentaliser eric meurice des sram
droite les mêmes qui lorsqu'il ya un
attentat jeudi à me dégoûter pour
l'attentât d'indiquer le l'honnêteté de
jean baptiste zemmour sont tout le temps
dans la provoc de toi et tout est de la
faute de l'immigration si on sait bien
connu les sert qu'à rappeler non mais si
c'est vous venez de le dire ça sur le
tapis
rien à voir avec le débat sur la journée
aujourd'hui l'examen ne parlait pas dit
mais la violence a rien à faire si la
violence n'a rien à faire dans notre
société personne ne mérite de claques
voit là et il est là pour aller au
contact des français c'est le rôle du
président de discuter avec l'ensemble
des français avec ceux qui sont pas
d'accord avec eux avec lui et ils
discutent ils essayent de dahra inventé
mais on n'a pas être dans la violence en
réponse à la pression n'est pas pour ça
moi je veux dire les gens ils
n'attendent pas ça donne bien sûr en
plus souvent moi je dis que je vais pas
pleurer milan pour une claque c'est bon
c'est pas très travaillé et manu il a
dit que c'est bon je dis juste que par
contre là ce que vous êtes en train de
faire c'est juste qu'en fait c'est
simple c'est l'extrême droite vos potes
et moi ni mes épaules lui c'est juste
moi attendait non mais c'est juste que
moi hier par exemple une vidéo où il ya
des insoumis on les prend on se prend en
photo en train de fouiller des insoumis
avec papa sitôt etc
oui bon
il théorise les théories se sentent
libres de wimy viol et marine le pen
mais c'est en quelle année nous l'avons
tué l'année quand nick conrad et qui
veut pas les blondes rigolade mais c'est
pour dire oui oui 46% non à 54 avec elle
à 57% qui n'ont pas choqué jean michel
petit